nihal seniviratna is a wholesale
commodity trader
a job he has done for more than 40 years
but today he's struggling as a result of
the country's foreign currency crisis
reserves have fallen to 3 billion
dollars the problem we are facing for
the last couple of months
is the banks unfortunately they say
today we don't have dollars
so sometimes they don't give even even a
date
so they say okay we are you are
waitlisted sanivaratna imports food
items from about
20 countries he's worried the delays
will affect his business
as he can't pay suppliers on time
that seems inevitable analysts say
reserves are heading to just six weeks
of imports
by the year end which would be a
critical phase for sri lanka
one analyst told al jazeera that a
three-pronged approach is vital
even at this late stage a full analysis
of incoming and outgoing reserves a
proper estimate of how long sri lanka
can manage with the reserves
and the plan to make sure the country
can pay its debt
problem we have today begins by the loss
of confidence and trust
of international financial markets of
sri lanka's ability to repay
which is why we can't refinance the
money we are
settling by borrowing a little more
which is what we did in the past
the government has dismissed concerns
about the state of the economy
saying it's got things under control and
is working according to a plan
that has the national interest at heart
policy that we have adopted
is that we don't want to add to the debt
that's why we are looking at
non-debt inflows and we have seriously
attempted to increase those we have
ensured that the remittances can be
continued and then certain imports are
reduced
asked if the government would go to the
international monetary fund for a
bailout
cabral said no analysts say the
government is like an ostrich with its
head in the sand
ignoring the dire economic position sri
lanka has fallen into
decision makers here say they have
things under control
millions of sri lankans are desperately
hoping
that's true miner fernandez al jazeera
colombo